[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
some video about two lines in the
nimzo-indian and it's um yeah combined
in one video because those two lines may
transpose into one another and share
similar ideas and concepts so we have
the starting position of the names ohm
and now the two lines that we are going
to examine are f3
and to move a three those two lines as I
said are somewhat similar in nature and
indeed sometimes transpositional in both
of them
White's idea is to build up a huge
center with f3 this is a more apparent
version actually where Eve or is an
immediate threat with a three-wide is
basically saying okay go ahead I don't
mind if you destroy my pawn structure if
I later can claim f3 and here for this
is the main later idea that white has
build up your Center and accept that the
Queen side is weakened um we're going to
start with a three in this video the so
called zimis variation yeah black is of
course capturing on c3 and after B takes
we see a clear outline the Queen side is
completely destroyed actually those two
pawns are weak and the whole Queen side
is weak squares and so on there's a huge
structural problem for white iam them
upside that white sometimes has is he's
got the bishop here of course and we can
play f3 or form as an idea and try to
steamroll us in the center on the King
side the same variation does not have a
very good reputation it is only very
rarely played on the top level sometimes
as a surprise weapon and as a surprise
it has been played even by by Magnus
Carlsen in blitz games so it's something
that should be taken seriously even
though it is probably not objectively um
the absolute best line for white um
black has a pretty wide choice him we
recommend to Castle this is a flexible
move and move that we probably want to
play anyway and now beam
[Music]
what White's next move is going to be
and then we have to react accordingly it
is very much noteworthy that against a3
on our on structure will be a lot more
diverse than it is usually in this
repertoire oftentimes d5 is the move
that we play like in the row goes and we
play d5 even before Bishop before we
play d5 against III but against this
image playing d5 is rarely a good idea
because if you imagine d5 at a later
stage and white takes this is something
that white is rather happy about he's
then able to get rid of one of them the
double pawn and improve his pawn
structure increases central control so
we should only play d5 in situations
where it's clearly basically beneficial
for us whereas like a technical
justification or a direct line we rather
want to be more flexible one idea on for
example is to directly play against them
against the weakened Queen side by means
of putting the Knight to a5 b6 and
Bishop a6 we'll see more that later now
there's a split white can try a couple
of motion the most dangerous one and
most principled one is probably f3 as
you probably have guessed mentioning
that if OS White's plan but there are
others not very dangerous moves down if
white plays III this would be a more
restrained version of the center
expansion first trying to develop we
play knight c6 the move knight c6 is
also going to be the answer to f3 and
this can basically described as a slower
version of that white is playing like
this and will often later try to expand
note that this position can easily arise
from a different move order where white
plays III or move four and then plays a3
after castling
is their form not examined here but in
the chapter on 43 this is by far the
more common way to get this um white can
also play Knight f3 the move Knight f3
however does not go all that well with
the idea to go for double pawns on the
queenside
if the reason is that um it is not
really supporting the central expansion
you want to go get a foreign and with 90
f3 you're not doing all that much in
that regard and we have a couple of good
answers to this move our suggestion here
is d5 in the spirit of the regos and in
fact this is a position that looks a lot
like a cosa me um here we can look at
some lines but you probably yet feel
very it will feel very familiar to you
the play from rico's and nines note that
here d5 is played i mentioned some
minutes ago that you need a concrete the
justification for that p.m. the
justification keishon is actually that
the night is on f3 because with d5 which
takes some claim in the center this was
a free preview of our entire one d4
course based on the names of Indian and
Rocco wasn't available on chess about
calm thanks for watching and see you
soon
[Music]